he earned his PhD in economics from
Harvard University and his BS in physics
from Caltech dr. Barrow is co-editor of
Harvard's quarterly Journal of economics
and was recently president of the
Western Economic Association and
vice-president of the American Economic
Association he is written as a viewpoint
columnist for Businessweek as a
contributing editor of The Wall Street
Journal he is the author or co-author of
a number of books including
macroeconomics a modern approach
economic growth nothing is sacred
economic ideas for a new millennium
getting it right markets and choices in
a free society and education and
modernization worldwide from the 19th to
the 21st century please join me in
welcoming to Hillsdale College dr.
Robert barro
well it's a great pleasure to be here
again and to be talking on one of my
favorite topics which is Milton Friedman
so my contact with Milton began in the
early 1970s I had been my first job was
as an assistant professor at Brown
University and then I managed to get
tenure there but then I visited in
Chicago and Milton persuaded me to give
up the tenure I had at Brown to move to
the University of Chicago
sometimes Milton's advice to me was not
as great as at other times and I'm not
sure that this was the wisest decision I
ever made but I guess it worked out okay
in the end just to prove that I actually
knew Milton here's a photo that was
taken by George Stigler Stigler was an
avid photographer who basically always
went around with his camera so we had a
regular doubles tennis group we played
in floss for Illinois which is where
George lived and this time it was Milton
in the center and I'm on the Left
Stiegler was a third member who took the
picture and Gary Becker normally was the
fourth participant in this doubles match
but he was out that day he was
substituted by Arnold's ilnur the famous
economy trician who's on the on the
right here now one of the benefits from
my going to Chicago in the early 1970s
was that Milton was still running the
famous money in banking workshop and he
had a very unusual approach to carrying
out the workshop which got to be known
as the page1 page2 method so Milton
would start out the workshop without
letting the speaker say anything and he
would just announce to the group who has
comments on page one and then somebody
presumably would say something and then
the speaker would be allowed to respond
and other people would chime in
and and so on
now milton claimed that the reason he
was following this format was that it
was a lot more efficient than the usual
method of having the author present the
paper and moreover he said it was good
because it forced the participants to
actually read the paper in advance
otherwise they would not have comments
on page 1 etc but I think the real
motivation for this approach was that it
gave Milton a much greater share of the
discussion time than otherwise would
have occurred and frankly I think that
was a benefit to everybody present
because normally Milton was much more
interesting than the author of the of
the paper so while I was preparing the
talk for today I went through my files
and I was quite surprised to find a
letter from Milton from 1987 which I had
completely forgotten about here's the
letter on Hoover Institution stationery
Milton retired from the University of
Chicago 1977 and moved to Hoover this is
written on August 5th 1987 he says do I
take the announcement of your change of
address to mean it you have accepted a
permanent position at Harvard or is this
a temporary move in either case let me
congratulate you so when I read this
note over having forgotten about it from
28 years ago I thought he was
congratulating me and he was just being
pleasant so I passed a note by my wife
and a couple of other people and they
actually had very different opinions of
what this letter really meant and my
wife in particular thought that Milton
was saying that what a big mistake I was
making by going to Harvard and that I
really should have stayed in Chicago all
along but I'm really not sure whether
that's what Milton intended anyway given
the derogatory remarks that Steve Forbes
had yesterday about Harvard
I'm going to send them this note a copy
of this note and see what he thinks
about it now I'm supposed to talk about
Milton Friedman and monetarism Milton
Friedman his macroeconomic guys
and of course Moulton was very famous
for his thinking particularly in the
monetary area but frankly I think
Milton's most important contributions to
economic knowledge were on the micro
economics side or really in terms of
applied price theory and his overarching
theme in that context was about the
benefits of free markets and private
enterprise and I think he was very
persuasive and showing how that worked
out in a number of policy areas now the
best book I think that exists in terms
of communicating important economics to
a general and wide audience is
capitalism and freedom which came out of
lectures that Milton had given in the
early 1950s and the book appeared I
believe it was in 1956 excuse me it
actually appeared later in 1962 so I
think anybody who's not a professional
economist who wants to gain knowledge of
a variety of aspects of economics that
this is still the best book to read and
frankly I'm amazed every time I go
through this book I learned something
new and I'm really impressed by what
Milton's thinking was this this long ago
so there are a lot of important policy
ideas that are expressed in capitalism
and freedom and many of these ideas seem
to be completely radical at the time
they were initially expressed such as
from the early 1950s up to 1962 so as a
selection of items that are in that book
we have the idea of an all-volunteer
army as opposed to conscription we have
the idea of privatized Social Security
which applies in many countries and
Cheil a is a particularly good example
of a system that seems to work
effectively he also proposed a negative
income tax as a kind of generalized form
of welfare that would replace an array
of existing welfare programs and the
Earned Income Tax Credit has the kind of
structure that Milton essentially laid
out in capitalism and freedom he had the
idea of a flat rate income tax which
applies currently in a number of
countries or localities and amazingly
enough that's true about both Russia and
Massachusetts two places that have a
communist heritage I suppose
he also had the idea of school vouchers
related to charter schools for example
which have become quite important in
many localities in the United States and
he also had a design of a welfare system
that would be more market oriented and
one of the amazing events in the 1990s
was that Bill Clinton actually
implemented a lot of these ideas I might
say that aside from rhetoric the two
presidents that have been the best in
terms of policies in the US since World
War two I would say were Ronald Reagan
and then Bill Clinton and even though
you listen to Bill Clinton today and he
can sound very anti-market and
unpleasant in terms of the actual
policies during his administration I
think they were mostly pretty good on an
economic perspective also in capitalism
and freedom we had the idea of open
capital markets which have become pretty
much the norm in the developed world we
had the idea of flexible exchange rates
which has also become quite prevalent he
didn't talk about decriminalization of
drugs in capitalism and freedom but I
think pressured partly by his good
friend Gary Becker eventually Moulton
came out in favor of decriminalization
of drugs he I think that was in
particularly some Newsweek column said
Milton had and I think this idea is
currently moving toward acceptance even
though a particular proposal was very
recently rejected in Ohio finally in
terms of topic more pertinent to what
I'm supposed to talk about today Milton
had strong arguments in favor of
monetary stability aimed especially
toward price stability toward low and
stable inflation and I think Milton has
been very successful in that general
concept although his specific famous
proposal which was a constant growth
rate rule for some monetary aggregate
has not proven to be successful and in
fact eventually Milton basically
retracted that idea
and that's the only idea I know of that
Milton once held firmly which he went
back on normally Milton didn't make
mistakes and I think in this context he
decided this wasn't really the optimal
way to conduct monetary policy from an
academic standpoint in terms of the
conceptual framework Milton's ideas on
money are laid out best in the essay the
quantity of money a restatement excuse
me they should say quantity theory of
money a restatement and then also in the
subsequent monetary history of the
United States which Milton wrote jointly
with Anna Jacobson Schwartz so those are
the two works that really lay out the
basic thinking that Milton had about
money and its role in the economy so
Milton's vision of the quantity theory
of money is what later became described
as monetarism so I don't really think
there's a distinction distinction
between those terminologies but there
were two key features that Milton
stressed in terms of what does it mean
to be a quantity theorist with respect
to money one is that in many
circumstances for example of looking at
history the nominal quantity of money
was determined in ways independent of
shifts in the real demand for money so
many circumstances you could think of
shifts and money that had occurred in
what economists would say was an
exogenous manner and then you could look
at what was the impact on the economy
from those changes the second thing that
Milton argued was a key feature of this
quantity theory was that the real demand
for money how much money people wanted
to hold in terms of purchasing power was
a stable function of a few key variables
which would particularly involve real
income and something like the nominal
interest rate which is a cost of holding
money so the idea is if you have these
two key features and then the Monetary
Authority controls the quantity of money
then indirectly the
because of the stable demand for money
you have influence over the basic
macroeconomic variables in particular
the price level but maybe also something
about real economic activity so in the
monetary history Milton along with Anna
Schwartz explored how money supply was
determined in the u.s. under different
historical regime regimes one of which
was the gold standard and they argued
that historically much of the movements
and money was independent of changes in
the demand and then you could look at
how did the economy respond in these
various periods and furthermore they
argue that the Association they found
between changes and nominal money and
changes in real economic activity that
these associations were typically
positive and in the main you could
interpret that as causal influence from
monetary shocks to real economic
activity so when money expanded it
tended to be that the real gross
domestic product went up and vice-versa
and that was interpreted as monetary
influences on real activity I might say
that the gold standard is certainly
examined in some detail in the monetary
history but my reading is that Milton
was not really a fan of the gold
standard there are a lot of positive
features of the gold stew in it I can
understand why a lot of people
appreciate that system and kind of have
a wishful memory in terms of going back
to that system but as Milton well
recognized there were also some major
shortcomings of the gold standard in
terms of what kind of economic mechanism
it put in place in the economy one
problem with a gold standard is that if
you fix the price of gold which is what
was done historically for periods of
great length both in the US and the UK
and elsewhere
it doesn't really ensure price stability
particularly over a short horizon
the relative price of gold and other
things is just too variable so pegging
the price of gold doesn't really give
you very good control over the general
price level which is normally what
you're interested in terms of creating
price stability it was also quite clear
historically that for example in the
United States it was a long term regular
history of bank runs and banking panics
which occurred under the gold standard
so the gold standard did not prevent
those kinds of disruptions in terms of
the financial and banking system so
question is whether we should think of
Milton is in some sense being a
Keynesian now the funny aspect of this
is that when Milton was writing
initially on monetary history and
similar events when he was writing in
the 1960s his views from were viewed as
anti Keynesian from a perspective of
typical macroeconomists and i think the
reason for that is that if you look at
Keynes's general theory then keynes
de-emphasized monetary disturbances as a
key element in business fluctuations and
he also didn't think that active
monetary policy was a an efficient
instrument for stabilizing the business
cycle
so therefore when when Milton was
particularly bringing out the important
real role of money in terms of economic
fluctuations as he did in a monetary
history that was counter to what Keynes
was arguing in the general theory and
for that reason Milton was viewed as not
being a Keynesian and with respect to
his 1960s thinking but later on typical
Keynesian sometimes called New Keynesian
'he's got the idea that by moving around
monetary policy in an active way you
could make use of the fact that money
was so powerful in influencing economic
activity and therefore use active
monetary policy to it
economic stabilization so that
perspective became since the 1980s a
hallmark of Keynesianism and that
viewpoint fit very well with what milton
was arguing about money in the economy
in the 1960s so in that respect Milton's
thinking became what you might call us
too much of a Keynesian approach now
Milton also had a very important article
in the 1967 American Economic Review
which was his presidential address
called the role of monetary policy
this article along would work by Edmund
Phelps foreshadowed what Bob Lucas led
in the 1970s as the rational
expectations revolution in
macroeconomics so the major element
there
was that in the long run money would be
neutral and if you had big changes in
money in the long run it would just
affect price level and it wouldn't
affect real economic activity but in a
short run unanticipated monetary
movements and unanticipated movements in
prices could have major real economic
effects that was the idea of Lucas and
that was the material that was in
Milton's 1967 presidential address now
if you take that view point he still get
the idea that monetary policy can be
quite important in terms of stabilizing
the real economy and the long-run money
would be neutral but in the short-run
money would have major real consequences
and then it's not too much of a leap
from there to argue that a wise monetary
authority maybe even the Federal Reserve
could do good things in terms of
stabilizing the economy so Milton's view
of money then became a defense for
activism particularly in terms of how
the Federal Reserve would intervene and
it's no wonder that this part of
Milton's monetary macro framework was
then embraced by Keynesian in the 1980s
and then thereafter so the question is
how do you go from Milton's monetary
framework which seems to
suggests that monetary policy could do a
lot to stabilize the economy to Milton's
practical advice for monetary policy
which was not to be activists and to do
something more like increase some
monetary aggregate at three percent per
year and then don't attempt to do
anything else there seems to be a
inconsistency between these two aspects
of what Milton had laid out now to
reconcile the two
you need a further argument like the
long and variable lags between monetary
impulses and real responses which Milton
laid out in another book a program for
monetary stability another idea along
these lines which inputs reinforces this
long and variable legs is a distinction
between rules and authorities or more
often called rules versus discretion
this line of thinking produces a benefit
from the monetary authority being
committed to something like price
stability and the fact that people can
count on that
rather than worrying about being
surprised by monetary stimulation in the
positive direction or by monetary
contraction in a negative way this is in
fact the chief feature of the gold
standard that's attractive if the
Monetary Authority is constrained to
maintain the price of gold that that's a
kind of commitment which avoids activism
and it avoids a lot of policy discretion
it has some other shortcomings that I
tried to lay out before but there is a
good argument along these lines about
why it's better if the monetary
authority doesn't give in to the
temptation to either try to inflate the
economy or to contract it now these
extensions of my Milton's monetary macro
framework can reconcile his theory about
money with his practical policy advice
which was that the monetary authority
should try to have price stability and
not seek to guide the economy in terms
of moderating business fluctuations
now Milton specific proposal was to pick
a monetary aggregate he thought about m1
which is currency and checkable deposits
he looked at a broader aggregate which
included a larger class of the short
term liquid financial instruments called
m2 and then his proposal was that you
should pick one of these and he ended up
preferring m2 and saying well the
Monetary Authority should just expand
this aggregate at something like two to
three percent per year and then
basically go home so it shouldn't do
anything more activist than that as what
he recommended the the problem with that
approach is that the real demand for
money is not that stable as I mentioned
that's one of the two key underpinnings
that milton laid out in terms of
thinking about the quantity theory of
money the stability of the real demand
for money but empirically it's not true
that a demand for money is that stable
and that means that by having a constant
growth path for a nominal aggregate you
don't really achieve price stability
you don't really achieve a low and
stable inflation rate now that's
particularly in parent in the recent
period in the recent period since 2009
we've had this dramatic run-up in real
m2 or real monetary base and a way to
think about that is that something has
dramatically shifted the amount that
people want to hold in terms of monetary
instruments in terms of currency in
terms of deposits that's run up
dramatically
but we haven't had much inflation now
frankly this is a big surprise to me if
you had told me in 2009 that the Fed was
going to raise the monetary base by
three trillion dollars within a few
years I would have said that that would
be tremendously inflationary and I don't
think it's that easy to explain what's
happened
although I can offer some ideas about
that so what's happened in terms of the
data monetary base has gone up like
crazy along with the expansion of the
balance sheet of the Federal Reserve
broader monetary aggregates have also
been growing very rapidly for example
Milton's favorite m2 has grown at over
6% per year since 2009 but we've not had
much inflation the average inflation
rate has been very low less than 2% per
year the only way you can understand
that is to allow for the fact that
there's been a dramatic increase over
this period in the real quantity of
money demanded the real amount that
people are willing to hold particularly
financial institutions now my
understanding of why that's happened is
that people are very nervous about this
economy there's been a tremendous
increase in uncertainty and a reaction
to that is to be more and more willing
to hold short-term liquid assets even
though they don't pay much of a rate of
return and that's why the nominal
interest rate can be close to zero and
real interest rates can be negative it's
because this worry about the future has
dramatically increased the real demand
for money that's my understanding of it
it's a an example of the real demand for
money being unstable but my particular
explanation certainly might not be fully
correct now one way or another a
successful monetary policy has to allow
the quantity of money
the nominal quantity to adjust to shifts
in the real demand and that's what
Milton's constant growth rate rule does
not do now a system that does allow for
these kinds of adjustments is inflation
targeting which has become quite
prevalent among world central bank's
particularly since the late 1980s now
this is a system where nominal interest
rates are moved by the central bank
whenever in particular inflation is
doing
something different from what is desired
so if inflation goes above a target like
say 2% per year the response of the
central bank is to raise nominal
interest rates and vice versa when the
inflation rate is too low and this
system was initially pursued in an
explicit form by New Zealand in 1989 and
it was adopted by most of the principal
central bank's and really has been in
place until the financial crisis of
2008-2009 when things became more
complicated now a key feature of this
system is that it allows the nominal
quantity of money to adjust
automatically when the real quantity
demanded moves around and that's what's
missing in the constant growth rate rule
that milton had proposed well let me
skip that now more recently there have
been difficulties in maintaining the
regime of inflation targeting for
example in the United States but also in
other countries when the nominal
interest rate got down to zero it really
was not feasible to go further to cut
when deflation was threatening so you
couldn't under the typical system have
nominal interest rates that were
negative so that's been the environment
for some years now in the United States
and in some other countries and because
of that some central banks including in
Japan but also in the US have moved back
to a system where they looked directly
at quantities of monetary aggregates and
that's often called quantitative easing
so the Federal Reserve following the
financial crisis and in 2009
particularly tried to expand the nominal
quantity of money and in conjunction
with that the Federal Reserve increased
the Matt dramatically the assets held on
its balance sheet now initially because
the crisis was focused on
mortgage-backed securities the Fed
emphasized printing money and buying up
mortgage-backed
which I thought was a very unfortunate
choice of policy because it was getting
the government into an area that it
should not be involved in which is
essentially subsidizing the credit for a
particular part of the economy which was
mortgages related to residential housing
subsequently the Fed shifted more toward
traditional open market operations in
quantitative easing word buy bought up a
lot of government bonds particularly
longer-term government bonds but I would
guess any month now the Federal Reserve
will finally move away from targeting a
nominal interest rate around zero and
will raise rates into positive territory
and I think they should have done that
actually many months ago well going back
to Milton's policy ideas I think anybody
who wants to know what Milton had been
thinking should as I mentioned start
with capitalism and freedom and then go
on to the work free to choose from the
early 1980s out of which a TV show was
made that made Milton into a household
name so for example I was once going
with Milton somewhere and we were in
O'Hare Airport in Chicago and someone
spotted Milton from across the way and
became almost hysterical as though
seeing a rock star and came up to us and
was trying to get Milton to sign
something or other and Milton told me
this sort of thing happened to him all
the time which I found kind of
surprising if you look at Milton's
memoirs which he wrote jointly with his
wife Rose he also mentioned that the
only European country that failed to air
free to choose on television was France
which I guess suggests that some things
never change
but so I also learned from Milton's
memoirs that he didn't do much in terms
of direct policy involvement with the
government in the 1930s in the mid 1930s
he was in New Deal Washington
apparently because he couldn't get any
other job which is kind of surprising
now that nobody wanted to hire Milton
Friedman and then he was again in the
government during World War two my
conclusion from what Milton says he did
while working for the government was
that he actually would not have been a
very good policy adviser or an actual
administrator or supervisor in the
government in fact the main thing he did
during World War two while working for
the US government was to help design the
system of federal income tax withholding
now Milton says and I think he's
probably right that no single act has
done more to expand the size of the
federal government than income tax
withholdings
you really can't have a dramatically
large government sector finance
particularly by an income tax without
tax withholdings and Milton certainly
regrets that he participated in that
part of the policy process but
nevertheless I guess I would have loved
to have seen Milton as chair of the
Federal Reserve of course they published
the meetings now I imagine the meetings
would have been pretty boring would
Milton as the chair he would have said
something like well we decided to expand
m2 at an annual rate of 3% and then
presumably would have been earned the
meeting so I guess they wouldn't have
taken very long
Milton also told a story in the memoirs
about what happened when he was the
president of the American Economic
Association which was in 1967 so Milton
was concerned that the Society had
accumulated a substantial surplus I
think at the time it was around eight
billion dollars something about that
magnitude but he was worried that the
Association was sitting with this money
with no particular designated use and
that some social do glitter would come
up with some ill-advised purpose for
which the money could go so Milton
thought that he could contribute to
general welfare and specifically to the
society by
coming up with a way to get rid of this
accumulated surplus so what he did at
the time was he started up a new journal
journal of economic literature without
raising the dues and that created a
deficit which then reduced the balance
that was at the AEA to something like
four million dollars so when I was a
vice president of the American Economic
Association in 1998 I was worried about
something similar because again the
Association had managed to accumulate a
large surplus so I remember I proposed
at the meeting that we should have a
major cut in the dues as a way to
eliminate the accumulated wealth of the
society the Society already had three
journals at that point so it didn't seem
like one could introduce another one in
order to use up the money but I failed
miserably at this proposal
unlike Milton who was very persuasive
and was able to introduce the new
journal without raising the dues I don't
think I got any votes of support in
favor of my proposal but a few years
later the Association actually did what
I had recommended and there was a major
cut into dues but nevertheless because
the Association has such a large scale
with people paying in membership dues
that it now has thirty two million
dollars in terms of its endowment this
is in 2014 so I think one would be
worried again about what are they gonna
do with this money so Milton also had
this famous quote which he discusses in
his memoirs this was in Time magazine in
December 1965 where it was quoted to the
effect of saying we are all Keynesian
now and Milton wrote a letter to time in
1966 explaining here's what I meant by
this statement in the first respect
I meant that Keynes had essentially
invented macroeconomics as a separate
field and I think that's true and in
that sense
Milton meant that any macroeconomists
was a Keynesian because you were using
the kind of macro apparatus that Keynes
had invented in the second sense Milton
would argue vacations said Milton
indicated in his letter from 1966 so I
think this is the most famous photo of
Milton Friedman so Milton's the short
guy in the middle and George Stigler is
the tall guy on the right no one seems
to know who took this photo but it's
clearly outside the Faculty Club at the
University of Chicago and probably
walking back to the Economics Department
after lunch so one thing you might
notice if you look carefully at this
photo is that Milton is squarely in the
middle of the road whereas George was
hugging the right edge of the road and
that reminded me of Milton's famous joke
I think this was from Milton to begin
with and he said with respect to policy
he said the problem would being in the
middle of the road is you get hit by
traffic in both directions but
apparently here he was in the middle of
the road but maybe it had nothing to do
with policy so this is actually my
favorite photo of Milton it's taken by
George Stigler who of course was always
taking photographs and I got this from
George's son Steven Stigler so Milton
here was getting a traffic ticket on the
Calumet expressway I think in 1972
that's outside of Chicago and he was
probably on the way to a tennis match so
I think here there's some lessons about
law and order because you can see that
Milton must have broken the law given
that he was pulled over but he also
seems to have a lot of respect for legal
authority since he's complying with the
instructions of the police officer so
gives you two important aspects about
the legal system one is that law and
order is very important for society but
secondly from an individual standpoint
sometimes it's rational to break the law
and that's apparently what happened in
this this case so I wanted to conclude
about the last time I actually saw
Milton so this was in the summer of 2006
at the Hoover Institution at Stanford
and I just chanced on Milton and Rose
walking on the steps outside of Hoover
and we got into some conversation and it
must have been on Milton's mind because
he told me out of the blue he said you
know I never planned to be living to age
94 and I don't think I've planned for it
properly and I'm not sure what I'm
supposed to be doing now that I'm still
alive
something like that so later that summer
I saw Milton for the last time lives in
San Francisco George Shultz is a fellow
of the Hoover Institution and of course
was Secretary of State and almost
everything else in the government was
hosting a party the party was in honor
of Tony Blair who was no longer in
office in the UK and I think Tony Blair
was looking for a job at the time was my
impression so there are many prominent
people present at this party that George
Shultz was hosting in San Francisco and
I recall asking someone I don't know why
I came up with this I said do you know
who is the most important person in this
room and the person I was talking to
didn't know how to respond to that and
kind of was thinking about all the
people who were present so I helped him
out by giving him the clear answer which
was Milton Friedman so that's it thank
you
thank you dr. bureau we now have time
for a few questions if you would raise
your hand and one of us will bring the
mic to you thank you for that very
informative talk is there any empirical
evidence that almost monetary easing
over the last number of years has really
improved the real economy it's a very
controversial topic I don't think
there's evidence that it's done
something positive for the real economy
and I think one has to start with the
observation that particularly since 2009
the recovery from the big recession has
been very anemic and in fact usually
what's true after you reach the trough
of a recession that a recovery features
economic growth at a rate that's above
average the long-term average growth
rate in the u.s. for the real gross
domestic product is about three percent
or about two percent per capita if you
look at it that way and the average
growth rate of real GDP since that
period has been about two percent which
means that we've lost relative to the
normal growth rate in what was supposed
to be a recovery I think the two main
policies that were followed by the US
government since the Great Recession
pretended in 2009 were a monetary
expansion that you alluded to and also a
dramatic increase in transfer payments
of various types and I think if you look
at the overall response I think you have
to say that the cumulative effect of
those two interventions has certainly
been disappointing and it doesn't look
like they have positive effects on
things
now of course it's much broader evidence
available on what is the effect of
monetary changes on economic activity
and there's some evidence about transfer
payments but I don't think there's
evidence that expanding transfer
payments is a good way to accomplish
economic growth
and I don't think it's right certainly
not right over six years that monetary
expansion is a way to get higher really
Kodama growth so I think I'm agreeing
with the spirit of your question which
is that I don't think it's been
successful
dr. barrow thank you so much for your
time this evening my question is going
to go back to your slide under inflation
rates and where you basically talked
about central banks and how they can
adjust an inflation rates and therefore
improving economic situations and
well-being thereby
my question is what is the criteria used
by these banks in order to determine the
appropriate rate of adjustment given the
spirit of Friedrich Hayek's knowledge
problem as well if you could mind
talking about that sir thank you very
much I think many banks have used
versions of what now it's called a
Taylor rule where you look at in
particular the inflation rate and you
have in mind a kind of target inflation
rate typically around 2% per year and
then there's a kind of quantitative
adjustment about how much you move
nominal interest rates particularly at
the short-term and in response to the
inflation rate but it's somewhat of a
trial by error type procedure I don't
think that it's really something that
comes out of some fitted model that has
a lot of explanatory power it's also
true empirically that central banks
don't react just to inflation in terms
of moving around interest rates they
also react to some measures of real
economic activity and in particular the
Federal Reserve has tended to focus on
the labor market so it tends to adjust
interest rates in response to
unemployment and an expense in response
to weak employment growth those are the
things that they've moved in response to
I don't know that it's particularly
useful for the central bank to be having
that kind of response to the real
economy it doesn't seem like it was all
that harmful in terms of say 20 years of
experience where we seem to have
achieved pretty good price stability
because if you compare the period from
the
late-1980s up to say 2009 what was in
place earlier it looked like there was
great success in terms of having
achieved good inflation stability at a
low rate without compromising in terms
of economic growth I think that so that
looked like a major achievement not only
at the Federal Reserve but of central
banks worldwide so I thought that that
was a positive thing but things have
become much more complicated since the
Great Recession of 2008 2009 dr. Beryl
thank you very much my question has to
deal with the current participation rate
in the economy and what do you think
Milton Friedman's response would be to
the fact that it's the lowest since
World War two I think some of that has
to do with expanded transfer payment
programs which have diminished the
incentive of people to be in the
workforce and in general to supply labor
I'm not sure what Milton in particular
would say on this he'd certainly worry
about the disincentive effects related
to high transfer payments that were
available in the same way that he would
be worried about high tax rates so in
effect if you lose a lot of transfer
benefits by deciding to work and be in
the labor force
that's just like having a high marginal
tax rate on the income that you earn so
you'd want to kind of combine for an
effective tax rate what you have to pay
along with the benefits that you lose by
by working more and by being in the
labor force so I think Milton would have
said that this is a consequence of the
kind of fiscal policy that was followed
would respect the transfers but maybe
I'm putting words in Milton's mouth with
regard to what he would have said but
that that would be my vision of that
thank you very much for your speech
and I am wondering do you anticipate the
kind of financial or economic collapse
that is heralded on so many television
commercials including from dr. Stockman
and other luminaries I think there are
various policy problems that have not
been seriously addressed for example if
you look at the long-term fiscal
imbalance that the US has which
particularly relates to entitlement
programs and if you look at the
inefficiencies in the tax system I think
there are serious reforms that need to
be made there I think President Obama
could have done this in 2010 he had a
very good Commission that reported on
what would be a good set of policies and
they chose to basically ignore it and
didn't put things in place I think it's
particularly true on the health care
side that if you look into the future
that the burdens are astronomical and
nothing's really been done to address
that in fact the changes that have been
made have expanded the burden because
they've increased the outlays without at
the same time including some reforms
that would be effective on the cost side
so I'm pretty nervous about the
situation in the US and globally I think
I mentioned that before when I was
trying to interpret why hasn't there
been more inflation in the US along with
the vast monetary expansion my way to
interpret that is in terms of the
increase in uncertainty and concerns
about future crises things that might
look like the financial crisis of
2008-2009 or some other kind of fiscal
related crisis so I think there's
serious reasons to be concerned now a
lot of people think that the long-run
rate of economic growth has also
declined now it is true if you look at
the US and a set of other rich countries
and you look at the average rate of
economic growth since say the
mm it's extremely low the growth rate of
real GDP per person since that period is
0.8 percent per year averaged over to us
and some other countries where the
typical average is 2% per year so in
terms of information over now 14 years
it looks like there's been a slowdown in
the average rate of economic growth
would you if you project that out into
the future it's a problem but I guess my
bigger concern bigger even than reduced
average growth is the potential for
another kind of crisis which i think is
certainly there dr. barrows well thank
you for coming and speaking a day
history has given us a number examples
of central banks who lose control lose
their independence and 10 this tends to
be really inflationary once governments
get control of the currency there's been
a lot of talk of auditing the Fed lately
do you support this and if so to what
extent do you think Congress should be
able to audit and regulate the Fed so I
thought that the policy of the Fed since
say 2009 has been really quite wild
basically the Fed has assembled a
balance sheet that resembles Lehman
Brothers in 2008 except that it's a much
bigger scale so they're basically
borrowing a lot of money short-term and
then holding a lot of assets which
initially were teased a lot of
mortgage-backed securities and then
subsequently a lot of longer-term
government bonds if it was a private
corporation doing that you would say
that looks very risky very worrisome
what's going to happen if we ever move
back to an environment where interest
rates go up to a normal level and if
there's some inflation and it looks like
the Fed was very vulnerable to that type
of problem and it still is so I'm
surprised that this problem hasn't shown
up yet in terms of higher interest rates
and in terms of inflation and I've tried
to explain maybe why that's true but
it's a very worrisome problem so I
thought this was a
stay conformed of policy but it hasn't
played out yet the way I would have
predicted so I have to acknowledge that
that's the case I think particularly
when the Fed got into the business of
buying up mortgage-related securities
which essentially going into the real
estate business that that was very
dangerous in terms of compromising the
independence of the monetary authority
because of the Fed is going to become a
fiscal instrument which is really what
it was doing by buying up particular
kinds of assets like that private sector
assets that that risks a lot of
interference or control by the Congress
because if the Fed is doing all kinds of
things beyond its mandate it becomes
more plausible that the Congress should
have 30 over them and they shouldn't
really be an independent entity but if
yes what do I think will happen if the
Congress gets more involved and they
audit the Fed and they start controlling
monetary policy that prism would be much
worse than the Fed acting on its own so
in that respect I'm not really a
supporter of the idea that Congress
shouldn't be more actively involved I
was more trying to advocate as I have to
people at the Fed over the last several
years that they shouldn't be doing the
kind of activities that compromise their
independence but I have to say again the
fact that inflation has been very low
and stable in this whole period is
something they can come back with and
say look in that respect these results
have been pretty good even though
economic growth has not been very strong
but I'm not really a in favor of
auditing the Fed and I don't know where
that's gonna go down the road in terms
of congressional monetary policy um dr.
Borrero earlier you spoke in my class
and you mentioned how you present your
Ricardian equivalence paper and when you
presented it Milton Friedman was in the
room along with George Stickle and Gary
Becker I believe it also just throughout
your time at Harvard in Chicago you've
been around a lot of other great
economists and I was kind of wondering
what it's like to work in that kind of
environment every single day
and also I'm an aspiring economist my
economist
it's always wondering if you have any
advice for someone like me so when I
went to Chicago in the early 1970s it's
true that the three great pillars of the
Chicago School were there Milton the
Longwood George Stigler and Gary Becker
I only saw them together in a seminar
once which was that time I presented
what subsequently became called
Ricardian equivalence in a and the money
in banking workshop I should say that
nobody said at the time that this is
Ricardian equivalence it's not like that
was a well-known phrase which really
means that the government financing
itself with taxes versus borrowing has
equivalent effects on the economy that's
what that recording equivalents means so
I could never figure out why George
Stigler in particular who was a great
historian of economic thought didn't say
during that seminar well there's
something in Ricardo that relates to
this idea but nobody said that and it
really wasn't until two years later when
Jim Buchanan said this is Ricardian
equivalence that I heard that idea and
then I went back and I looked what to
add what David Ricardo had and in his
main book it's actually pretty
incoherent but he had a pamphlet called
funding system which is quite obscure
and hard to find where he does actually
lay out something that sounds like
recording equivalence and then I sort of
looked at that now there's something
called stigler's law stigler's law says
that nothing has ever named after the
person who invented it and then the
funny part of that is supposed to be
that that's also true of stigler's law
because apparently that came from robert
merton senior who was a scholar and
history of science who was at MIT and
then stephen Stiegler the George Stigler
son modified stigler's law to say that
famous things are always named after
the second person to invent them so that
doesn't seem to work for Ricardian
equivalence which you mentioned so when
I heard that this was supposed to be
recorded in equivalence I spent a lot of
effort looking at things before Ricardo
and his major book from in 1810 or 12 or
something like that and I figured it
would be easy to find an earlier
treatment of something that amounted to
recording equivalents and of course the
first place I looked was it at Adam
Smith's Wealth of Nations but I spent a
lot of effort and I couldn't find
anything before Ricardo that sounded
like Ricardian equivalence and if you
look at Adam Smith on these matters
about the government financing itself by
taxing versus borrowing it's actually
not very well organized and it doesn't
have a coherent argument about what the
effects would be so in the end I
accepted the idea that yes this is
recording equivalence and I think that
that's a very nice terminology so anyway
I of course greatly benefited by working
with Milton and Gary Becker and George
Stigler at Chicago looking back on it
now I probably shouldn't have left
Chicago in 1975 because even though the
place was basically crazy aside from
those three guys as you say working with
people like that sort of makes it all
worth it so maybe I should have stayed
there and possibly I would still be
there
if I had stayed there in 1975 but I
didn't end up doing it now despite what
Steve Forbes said last night Harvard
also has a lot of great economists I
think it's a terrific department and
even though Harvard has a reputation of
being kind of leftist which is
particularly well deserved if you look
outside of the Economics Department I've
found it a very congenial atmosphere for
me to operate in a lot of people have
different views from what I have on
macroeconomics
and about policy activism and that
what's happened particularly since the
financial crisis in 2009 but it's
certainly a climate where one can
operate would one's views without
feeling any kind of hostility or
anything like that
so I found Harvard a very good place to
operate in it it's very different from
the Chicago of the 1970s but I think
it's a very positive place I don't know
if that helps you in terms of advice for
you personally but that's my outlook on
particularly Chicago and Harvard we have
time for one more question the great
last question or not but if I was a if
I'm a person and are a bunch of poor
people and don't have a great deal of
talent or hope of really escalating my
income why would I be jumping up and
down and having the when the economic
gurus say 2% is great inflation
why would I say 2% deflation which
whatever if I was a poor person but I
like 2% inflation or 2% deflation as a
policy objective I think what poor
people and everybody else are really
interested in is what is happening over
time to the real command of resources
that they have so you would think about
real income you would think about real
consumer expenditure and in the first
instance whether inflation is plus 2 or
minus 2 percent doesn't necessarily
matter that much for what's happening in
real terms so if everybody's nominal
income is going up at some rate that is
compensating for inflation then that's
basically fine at least on the first
order now I also think it's true since
you were talking about poor people I
think poor people have a lot of stake in
overall economic growth and sometimes
it's thought that the focus should best
be on redistributing income and not what
happens to the total pie which is about
overall economic growth now I think the
strongest indication of that about why
overall growth is so important is
something in the data that you get since
around 1980
from China and India China and India
have been two champions of economic
growth China since the late 1970s India
since the mid 1980s and because those
countries have so many people the
long-term growth that's occurred in
those two places has moved millions of
people out of poverty and in particular
if you look at China and hundreds of
millions of people now no longer below
the poverty line because of the overall
economic growth in that country I don't
think there's anything comparable to
that in world history in terms of
improving welfare so I think that's what
should give everybody maybe even
including Pope Francis a stake at
thinking about overall economic growth
and efficient ekun economies and not
just think about the rich giving to the
poor because a that example China and
India over the last 30 years I think is
very compelling and it suggests that
somebody who cares about the lot of poor
people should be particularly focused on
what is it a determines real economic
growth especially over the long term and
that's my main focus in terms of
thinking about good macroeconomic
policies whether in the relation to the
recent Great Recession or in a broader
context thank you very much dr. Barrow